[Music]
and today on tasty kitchen we'll be
making three vintage recipes from the
1900s and here's miss jasmine pack our
host to show us how hello there let's
get started
our first dish today will be the banana
candle a what
first cut bananas in half
[Music]
there we go
then brush with lemon juice this is
interesting i've never done this before
arrange the bananas in the pineapple
hole
i'm so sorry this is so funny okay
continue
once the banana is in the pineapple hole
use a vegetable peeler to remove orange
peel in one-inch slices use a paring
knife to trim the sides to create
straight edges
then use a toothpick to attach to the
banana it's so cute to give the effect
of candle wax drizzle the banana with
mayo
sorry
to simulate a flame use a toothpick and
a cherry to attach it to the top of the
banana
[Music]
it mainly just tastes like bananas and
pineapple i can't even taste the mayo i
think it was fun to try this time and
just this time
[Music]
in a large mixing bowl whisk together
the lime jell-o and boiling water until
the gelatin is completely dissolved
whisk in cold water
vinegar
and grated onions
grated onions grated onions
it just plopped next pour one cup of the
mixture into the bottom of a greased
jello mold now we're gonna let these set
in the fridge for about an hour to 75
minutes this one should be the
consistency of egg whites and this one
should be set until it's firm but not
too firm now that the jello is chilled
use a rubber spatula to fold in cottage
cheese and mayo
yum
i've never done this to my jello before
i'm actually not very picky so the
chances of me liking it are actually
quite high then pour the mixture over
firm jell-o so chunky
[Music]
just like mama made it now put back in
the fridge and chill until firm
preferably overnight remove the jello
from the mold and place on a platter
jiggly wiggly beautiful perfection i do
like this part very relatable now we
have to make the seafood salad in a
large mixing bowl combine the crab mayo
celery
red onion dill
old bay salt
and pepper
i always do big pinches of black pepper
so good place the tossed seafood salad
in the center of the jello and arrange
the salad greens around the outside of
the ring yum
[Music]
not gonna lie i'm not looking forward to
this one
so good i had to eat it really fast i
really liked it
just listen to it
that won't make the cut i think there's
a reason
i think there's a reason that this is
not a popular recipe nowadays that's
really gross guys
[Music]
for our main dish we'll be making
meatloaf igloo in a large mixing bowl
combine the ground beef bread crumbs
minced onion salt pepper and evaporated
milk oh i can tell this is going to be
really tender once combined pack it
tightly into a bowl lined with plastic
wrap to get that igloo shape remember to
leave a small handful in the mixing bowl
you'll need that to form the entrance to
your igloo invert the bowl onto a
greased aluminum lined sheet tray and
remove the plastic wrap wow
it's beautiful
place the remaining meat mixture on the
front of the meat mountain and fix to
look like the front of an igloo now bake
at 325 degrees for one and a half hours
in a small saucepan whisk together the
water evaporated milk salt and butter
bring the mixture to a boil and remove
from heat next whisk in the instant
potatoes i love me some taters
smells good whisk potatoes until they're
nice and thick
take the potato mixture and spread it
evenly and cross the baked meatloaf i'm
not gonna lie i love meatloaf but i know
a lot of people who despise it to their
very core oh my god my stomach's growing
so much this smells so good all right i
think it's good nice and smooth use a
skewer to carve in lines to get that
igloo look this is a lot harder than i
expected once your masterpiece is
complete go ahead and pop it in the oven
for 15 minutes after baking place a
slice of cheddar cheese on top of the
baked igloo and bake until melted
beautiful
[Music]
home run meat loop igloo
meatloaf
that sounds weird eat loaf
meatloaf
meatloaf igloo home run this is so good
not sure if i would do it again as a
meatloaf igloo i think i would just make
the meatloaf and have mashed potatoes on
the side but i do admire the hard work
that was put into it this was a lot of
fun i feel like i was able to transport
back into that time and really get into
it if you guys want to see us do some
vintage recipes again let us know in the
comments below thanks guys bye
[Music]
you